Imagine for a second
that your job was made redundant
by an advanced piece of software
that could do the work
at the same level of quality for free.
But you happen to have three years left
on a guaranteed contract,
and so your employer
gives you two options.
Either you can keep getting paid
as per your contract, but stay home
as the software does your job,
or you can keep going in
and doing the work
that could have been automated
for the same money.
What would you do?
Now most of you, I'm sure
this is a no-brainer.
Take the money, go home,
watch TED talks.
(Laughter)
But there's always some
who would choose to keep working.
What do you think of those people?
What does it say about their character?
This is the scenario about a hypothetical
medical scribe named Jeff
that we gave to our research participants.
For half the people in the study,
the story ends with Jeff
choosing to go home,
and for the other half it ends
with him choosing to keep working.
And then we asked everybody
what they thought of Jeff.
Those who heard about the Jeff
who kept working
saw him as less competent --
he does seem like a bit of a chump --
(Laughter)
but they also saw him
as warmer and more moral,
somebody who could be trusted
to do the right thing.
They saw him as a good person.
Even though Jeff added no extra value,
people saw him as virtuous
for choosing to keep plugging away.
Why is it that we see
mere effort as moral?
I am a psychology professor
at the University of British Columbia,
where I study morality.
I've worked on religion and morality,
I've worked on driverless
cars and morality,
but recently my collaborators and I
have been working on work itself.
And in study after study, we find
that people attach moral worth to effort
regardless of what that effort produces.
So in another study, we asked people
about two widget makers.
They produce the same number of widgets
in the same amount of time
at the same level of quality.
But for one of them, it takes
a lot more effort to do so.
People see that harder-working
widget maker as, again,
less competent but again, more moral.
And if you had to choose just one
of those two as a cooperation partner,
you would choose the one who struggles.
We call this effort moralization.
And it doesn't appear to just
be a North American thing.
Work norms, of course,
differ around the world,
but we replicated our original
American result in South Korea,
which is known by the numbers
to be one of the hardest-working
countries in the OECD,
and in France, which is known
for other strengths.
(Laughter)
In all of these places,
the harder-working person
was seen as more moral
and a better cooperation partner,
even though they added no extra value.
And it looks like this is something
broader than, say,
the Protestant work ethic.
Even the Hadza people,
hunter-gatherers in Tanzania,
show something like it.
When asked what qualities
contribute to good character,
they didn't agree on very much,
but they did agree on two things.
Generosity and hard work.
So this intuitive connection
between effort and morality
doesn't appear to be the quirk
of any one culture,
but potentially something
very deep indeed.
Now effort moralization makes sense
at the individual level.
Somebody who is willing to show
that they will put effort
into even meaningless tasks,
maybe even especially
into meaningless tasks,
is somebody who's more likely
to help you out.
So I have a friend from work, Paul.
Paul is an uncommonly charismatic man.
Paul wears stylish pairs
of raw denim jeans
and Paul buys expensive bars of soap,
60-dollar bars of soap.
And Paul is one of those types
who wakes up every morning
and goes running.
And when I first heard this,
I sort of rolled my eyes at this being
one of those Mr. Perfect things.
Actually, Dr. Perfect in this case.
(Laughter)
But then one day I saw Paul
on one of his morning runs,
and instead of seeing a sleek,
type-A personality
confidently striding through life,
I saw Paul struggling,
in an inelegant hobble
(Laughter)
with a grotesque grimace of something
between annoyance and agony on his face.
Running was hard for him.
Every morning was effort,
and the person who was willing
to wake up for that, day after day,
is the kind of person
you want in your corner.
And Paul is in mine.
He's not just the inspiration behind
some of the studies in this research,
he is a collaborator on them as well.
And he's a good man.
The truth is, we're all in the market
for finding the best
collaborators in life.
And we're trying to show others
that we are that person as well.
The evolutionary psychologists
call this partner choice.
Just as we are trying to be and select
the best romantic partners,
we are also trying to be and select
the best cooperation partners.
We're all trying to surround ourselves
with people who will
help us out in a pinch,
who won't slack off,
who will share things fairly.
And as a result,
any quality which makes you
a better cooperation partner,
say, generosity
or self-control or hard work,
is seen as a moral quality.
And so we have this simple heuristic:
people who work hard are good.
It's why you're more likely
to donate to your friend
who pledges to run a marathon
for cancer research,
than your other friend who pledges
to watch a "Sex in the City" marathon
for the same cause.
(Laughter)
But what makes sense
at the individual level
can still become very problematic
when scaled up to the societal level.
Our intuition that effort is good
for its own sake,
regardless of what it produces,
has created a work environment
with perverse incentives.
So when we start
attaching worth to activity
rather than to productivity,
we start caring more
about whether somebody is a hard worker
than whatever it is that that work
was supposed to achieve.
And this can come
at a very steep human cost.
So you'll remember our example of Jeff,
the medical scribe who chose
to throw his time into the volcano
as a sacrifice to the gods of hard work.
That was just a contrived scenario.
But how many Jeffs are out there,
taking time that could have been spent
on love or on leisure
and spending it on signaling effort?
And how often are we Jeff,
wearing workaholism as a badge of honor,
a way to reassure people
that we are a good person,
even if the person you're just trying
to reassure is yourself?
The anthropologist David Graeber wondered
how capitalism could sustain so many
of what he bluntly called bullshit jobs.
These are jobs in which even the people
doing the work see it as pointless,
accomplishing nothing of societal worth.
A capitalistic system should root out
those inefficiencies,
but it doesn't.
And the reason it doesn't
is because alongside capitalism,
we also operate under another system.
What the journalist
Derek Thompson calls workism.
Workism is about your job not just
being the source of your paycheck,
but the source of your identity
and your pathway to self-actualization.
Now that works for some people,
but what makes workism a culture
is that we all get forced to participate.
Partner choice is not just about being
a good cooperation partner,
but a better cooperation partner
than the next guy.
Not just hard working, but harder working.
And this can create
these arms races of workism.
So you can imagine two office workers,
both keen to show
how industrious they are,
both keen to be the first car
in the parking lot in the morning.
And so they start one-upping each other
by arriving earlier and earlier
and earlier in the morning.
And everybody else just seems
like more of a slacker every day.
The culture punishes us
for not keeping up.
And so we end up putting more and more in
regardless of what comes out
the other side.
And the culture maintains
the most laborious aspects of our jobs
because it most appreciates us
when it sees us putting in that labor.
And as a consequence,
every other aspect of our job
and our lives, however great,
is made just a little less important.
Now, this is not an argument
against hard work.
It's not.
Hard work can be extremely
meaningful when it serves a purpose.
Hard work built civilization.
But how much of the effort we spend
now is done to build nothing
but our own moral reputations.
To just convince other people
that we are hard workers.
And how much of what we admire
in others is just effort porn?
In one of his more candid moments,
one of my graduate students
said that he noticed
I would send emails out
at all hours of the day,
1 am, 2 am, 3 am.
Now, this was because being a professor
allowed me to maintain
an adolescent sleep schedule
deep into my 30s.
(Laughter)
But what he then did was he got some app
which scheduled his replies to come to me
at one or two in the morning
so as to make it seem like
he was also working all hours of the day.
I'd clearly sent the wrong message,
so much so that my student
was willing to delay the work
to make it seem
like he was more industrious.
It was literally bullshit work.
I had to change my lab's culture.
I had to convince my students
that we weren't just
about the show of work,
but what we were actually producing.
And it's not such a simple thing to do.
The mental circuit that connects effort
to morality can be a stubborn one.
When I teach about psychological
biases to my intro-psych students,
I tell them that you can't always
learn to resist a bias,
they can be very deeply ingrained,
but you can learn to notice them
so that you can account for them
when making important decisions.
We may not be able to break
that mental circuit,
but we can learn to recognize our biases
so they don't run our lives.
There is a story,
almost certainly apocryphal,
about perverse incentives
in the era of British rule in India.
Desperate to deal with the cobras
that were overrunning colonial Delhi,
a bounty was put up
for every cobra skin that was brought in.
But the plan backfired
because enterprising Indians started
breeding more cobras to kill them,
bring in the skins and collect the bounty.
And when the government
finally abandoned the plan,
as the story goes,
the breeders then released
the cobras into the city
and the snake problem was worse than ever.
Oops.
(Laughter)
The plan went awry because of the distance
between what they wanted,
which was fewer cobras,
and what they asked for,
which was an imperfect signal
of fewer cobras,
dead cobras.
But I fear we've done
something very real
and very similar with work.
We have built a culture
that asks for the wrong thing.
If all we ask from each other
is the effort that we put in,
we will create a world full of effort
and of hard labor and of cobras.
But if what we ask from each other
is to produce something meaningful,
we will create a world full of meaning.
And what could be more moral than that?
Thank you.
(Applause)